please welcome back to the show billy
barter
[Applause]
oh my goodness oh my god isn't that
thank you everybody for showing the love
i'm so
i'm so
that guy the last time i was here you
didn't have an audience and i sang to a
flower
i have a lot of questions for you
because you've been raw vulnerable real
honest in your life which
i have too
but in this book you really peel back
those layers
you know when we are in the public eye
when we are
you know
people who choose hope
people who choose optimism it's a choice
it's a practice it's a daily practice
and simultaneously other things can be
going on on the inside for me
there was a lot of trauma and grief that
was unprocessed
in my life for a very long time
and um you know recently within the last
five ten years
i've been working through
healing that trauma and and a part of
that is
this book it's called unprotected and
the subtitle for me which is not
necessarily it's not on the book printed
on the book but the subtitle is
healing trauma through my art healing my
trauma through my art um
that's what it's about
that is the gift
for me of being an artist
is that i've had a place
to um
put my trauma
you know i have to i'm i'm still
processing
all of this trauma and all of this grief
to get to
real
joy
right yes
i think it is through inventory yeah
also that we realize
oh
you know i i it can be something as
simple for me when i did inventory i was
like i have no more baggage with my mom
i'm totally free of it i've been
carrying it my whole life and until i
took that inventory and i really asked
myself how do i feel about this now in
my 40s as a mother now myself am i a
woman i don't know i grew up as you know
a showbiz kid when you're making paying
the rent and working in diapers right
you know it's confusing you're not a kid
you're not and i was like i am actually
healed of this thing and i can approach
this as an adult and i'm curious as to
but then
there were other traumas i realized i
hadn't dealt with a lot of my coping
mechanisms were still
very
childish
what trauma
you know are did you
go into the book
wanting to heal
what writing the book trauma came up and
did you realize i have not dealt with
that well the index trauma which is
you know the trauma of sexual abuse
you know at the hands of my stepfather
from the time i was seven to the time i
was 12 has been a really truly
everyday defining
thing in my life and it affects
everything and what the book has been
able to do is i've been able to
um
put it down on paper
and put it in its
place in its category you know um the
world stopped during covet so i could
heal myself you know i went into trauma
therapy there are exercises the the the
you know the psychiatric world is
the work and the things that they have
developed over the years and the skills
they have developed over the years are
remarkable
you know
it's very expensive a lot of people
don't have
the resources to afford it i'm just
saying the truth yeah you know i'm
blessed to have been able to afford
that
so that i could understand
how to really
once again i just keep saying it
heal
and
when you work through things new things
come up you don't get to say great i'm
done you're never done healed i think
that's the thing and i think that's the
the message
also that we have to make clear
is that life is a journey
it's not a destination right we can
continue to learn and continue to grow
until our last breath that is what i'm
interested in uh that's what i'm
interested in and can it be
the journey of once i work through this
it's not great more stuff comes in it
never ends it's
i'm checking
spiritual boxes to realize i'm no longer
that child living in that trauma i am an
adult away from it looking in a review
mirror ready to heal and move and
[Applause]
i put it all out there okay so when i
was 13 and got outed for being
institutionalized what gave you that was
a choice made for me and i said you know
what
oh wow
not how i would have handled it
but this is my truth so i'm going to use
it as my weapon and my tool and my
arsenal to be relieved that i no longer
have to pretend to be perfect right
especially in a hollywood situation
where there's a lot of veneers yes
how did you
find your bravery to come out and talk
about hiv which
changed the world
you you literally changed the world when
you did that because you brought light
into a space of darkness secrecy
and illuminated a path for people to
feel less alone
and
i thank you so much for that
because i feel like i walk this earth so
that people can know like
i'm with you what i understood
is that
from the minute i could comprehend
thought
from the minute
that my beautiful lovely very caring
family
who i love dearly
sent me to a psychologist when i was
five
because i was a [ __ ]
so the messaging that i got was
something is wrong with you and you need
to be ashamed of yourself
and fixed so
shame is the only thing i knew
then i was gay
so gay connected to my church bubble
you're an
abomination social
uh
you know governmental
sanctioned homophobia
you're wrong you need to be fixed
coming out at the age of 16 in 1985 in
the middle of the aids crisis trauma
something's wrong with you you need to
be fixed
then in 2007
getting the very thing
that everybody from my church pulpit
said was god's punishment
right i got it
shame shame shame shame shame shame
shame it's the only thing i ever
knew and i finally said
shame as a silencer
shame is a murderer
and i need to live
because i have stuff to do i have work
to do there's a calling on my
life there is a purpose for my life
there is a ministry in what i do
and i have to be sane
to do it so i'm gonna do that
and that's why i did it you know to
release
the shame
and look look at it now
you know it's it's
it's powerful
it's very very powerful and i did all of
what i did and that's the thing about
reading this book and going back
everything that i've been able to
accomplish i accomplished
stuck in the quagmire and under the
cloud of shame imagine what i'm getting
ready to do now
imagine i have no idea
i have no idea but i'm ready
[Music]
you